sur ce point de sur ce point de
l'éloignement et du rôle de nos services
de police vous à vous apporter deux
témoignages le premier d'abord deux
chiffres pour les personnes qui sont
placés en rétention
je voulais dit tout à l'heure seulement
57% sont éloignés
quarante trois portions ne sont pas on
l'a évoqué ce qui nous laisse une marge
de manoeuvre importante pour avancer
pour les personnes placées en
assignation à résidence
seuls 19% des personnes assignées en
résidence sont effectivement éloigné
donc 81 % de ces personnes ne sont pas
éloignées le texte aujourd'hui qui nous
est proposée par le gouvernement
ces deux prix donner la priorité à
l'assignation à résidence inutile de
dire que deux fêtes c'est la certitude
que nous ne le gagnerons quasiment plus
personne
si on donne cette priorité dans le
législatives aujourd'hui il faut donc un
la combattre 2 sans doute sur les
centres de rétention continuer
d'améliorer saucisses il ya déjà un gros
travail qui a été fait
dans le précédent quinquennat il faut
dire les choses telles qu'elles sont
mais ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point pour nos services de
police natacha bouchart maire de calais
qui étaient là tout à l'heure et
guillaume a dit qu'il y était allée g
chacun fait son voyage
j'y suis allé à jeudi dernier et nous
sommes allés évidemment voir dans ce
qu'ils appellent la jungle dans la lande
et surtout rencontrer les forces de
police les forces de police sont épuisés
et puiser du travail qu'on leur demande
et surtout ils ont le sentiment mais ce
n'est pas qu'un sentiment c'est une
réalité de travailler pour pas grand
chose
parce qu'en réalité il n'y a pas de
poursuites pénales sur les infractions
constatées
il y a donc en tous les cas sur ce qui
se passe à calais je le considère comme
tel
une vraie d'émissions de l'ordre
républicain c'est une véritable
démission de la république 1 à calais en
ce moment mais c'est aussi l'image de ce
qui se passe partout sur notre
territoire à la matière et plus loin
bien sûr voilà je vais pas être plus
long puisqu'on a prévu un petit temps de
parole que j'ai utilisé gentiment avant
de pouvoir passer à un autre sujet qu'on
n'abordait l'occasion de la première
table ronde qui était à savoir
immigration mais intégration
assimilation quelques vues noté
nationale pour demain quelle capacité à
accueillir avec quels moyens et c'est
donc valérie valérie rosso debord qui
sur ce point sur la politique
d'intégration